we're living in a fascinating time we're
living in a time where women have money
okay which is do you realize how new
that is right that's like 30 years old
or something and there's no blueprint
for how to operate and i think it's
really messing up the power dynamic like
the fact that i've been paying my own
bills that's such a big deal for me i
thought that making money was gonna
solve all my problems especially my
relationship problems because when i was
in my 20s i had to date guys that had
money because i didn't have any but now
that i make my own money i felt like it
opened up this whole new pool
of broke guys
that i couldn't date before so i've been
doing that
they're much nicer
and
last guy i dated i paid for everything i
paid for trips i paid for dinners and
now that i've sort of been the man in
the relationship now that i've been in
your shoes i now understand why you guys
hate us
it's because we owe you so much fucking
money
and something happens
psychologically when you start to pay
for someone where you start to hate them
you sort of hate everything about them
you resent them you start keeping score
of everything they do one day he came
home he was drinking a coconut water
it's like coconut water what are you the
queen of fucking england
how about you drink out of the tap like
a goddamn man how about that
and then they nag you they always need
something from you you know he'd be like
do you want to go to dinner i'm like you
just ate yesterday
do you have a tapeworm what's the
problem
i feel like i now understand why you
guys are always so disappointed in us
too because something happens when you
start paying for someone where you start
to get these high expectations for their
behavior like as soon as i started
paying for him i started expecting him
to like do chores
out of nowhere like one night we went to
dinner i spent 200 on dinner the next
morning i woke up i was like this is
weird it's 8 am and i don't smell eggs
yeah chop chop bitch mommy's hungry
[Music]
[Applause]
it's tricky i also started noticing all
these like unspoken rules that happen
with the expectations based on who pays
like the expectation if the man pays for
the woman is that she's gonna have sex
with you right but when i was paying for
the man the expectation was i am not
gonna have sex with you
and we're gonna stay up all night
talking about my dreams
i'm gonna read some horoscopes tonight
bitch
and then i saw like all the insidious
like institutionalized sexism like every
time we would go to dinner the waiter
would automatically give him the check
and then he would fucking take it and
then when the waiter would leave he
would slide it over to me i was like
oh hell no
if you take the check you're paying you
better find yourself a groupon real fast
[Applause]
i also get now why people stay in
relationships too long because money
makes uh makes things stickier like i
feel like i stayed in that relationship
three months too long just because i
didn't want to get a bad return on my
money
because dating is such a terrible
investment
which made me think like i can't believe
we just run around spending money on
relationships that we don't know is
gonna work out it's a terrible
investment i feel like there should be
some kind of insurance
in place to protect us like i feel like
dating
should be like checking into a hotel
okay you and i are gonna start dating
as soon as we start dating you have to
put your credit card down
three months later if you want to break
up i'll be like all right well let's
look at your bill
yeah you owe me 3 200
or you can't fucking leave